welcome back to the Mass Effect
Andromeda gameplay series in our first
installments we took a closer look at
combat gameplay today we're diving
straight into the heart of Mass Effect
Andromeda exploration
in addition to beautiful story missions
Andromeda's filled with worlds to
explore no way so our stories contained
within the Helius cluster a portion of
space populated with dozens of star
systems and The Tempest is where that
exploration begins you can navigate star
systems using the tempest galaxy map
from planets two moons two anomalies and
starships wherever you are in Helius
you'll now be able to see everything
that exists outside the ship's main
windows in real time in Andromeda there
are over a hundred planets to discover
and a handful of beautifully crafted
worlds can be landed on and that's where
the adventure really begins each world
you visit has its own story its own
characters and of course its own
challenges today the world we're going
to visit is called el eden exploring the
opening landing area called paradise
you'll quickly discover that the heat on
this planet can be deadly water is
scarce a mysterious ancient artifacts
dot the landscape guarded by dangerous
remnant creatures basically to live here
you have to be desperate or Krogan but
even the krogan aren't happy and they
don't trust anyone from the initiative
least of all a pathfinder how you deal
with the krogan and these challenges
will ultimately determine your success
on elegant we need the krogan and the
krogan need us before you set out you'll
get an update from your AI pointing out
key locations suggest this was indeed
supposed to be her golden walls we're
going to start the adventure by heading
over to the krogan colony but the choice
of where to go is ultimately yours
our all trained Rover the Nomad is key
to quickly covering the expansive
landscapes throughout Andromeda you can
also enhance the Nomad with a series of
functional upgrades designed to give you
better turbo-boost higher jumps better
handling and more while you're exploring
one of the key objectives will be to
discover locations to call down forward
stations once found each of these will
act as a fast travel point and allow you
to change your loadout or call the Nomad
if it gets lost or destroyed they also
offer resupply and protection from any
environmental hazards our conversations
of the krogan colony point us in a few
directions exiles are causing trouble at
their base the flophouse a derelict
remnant ship may have a dr coeur the
krogan are in desperate need of let's
head to that ship and see what we can
find out here we are more exposed to the
heat in Andromeda all of the planets
have localized and our global hazards
the Pathfinder in the no matter both
separately outfitted with life-support
systems that help protect against these
hazards but once you run out you'll need
to find a safe location or afford
station to recharge I'm rating a normal
temperature range Pathfinder as you
travel throughout the world you'll find
new areas to explore new characters and
new storylines ultimately all of these
discoveries will help raise the
viability of the planet
increasing planet viability does two
things allow for the creation of an
outpost and upgrade the Nexus the
Andromeda initiatives space station
before a planet can support an outpost
you'll first need to get its viability
to at least forty percent by pacifying
threats align yourself the locals
solving environmental problems and
accomplishing specific tasks related to
that planet story for example in the
case of elevate your relationship with
the krogan will determine whether you
can build here or not regardless of
whether you build an outpost your
exploration and discoveries will also
give you Andromeda viability points
reaching thresholds will allow you to
upgrade the Nexus and wake up more
colonists from cryo sleep oh you decide
to wake up will determine what perks and
advantages you'll get will you wake up
scientists to give you an edge in
research and development military
personnel to give you an edge in combat
or merchants to give you a leg up in
trading but of course not everything on
these worlds will be so straightforward
[Music]
Andromeda holds many mysteries not the
least of which is a vast network of
ancient bolts simply figuring out how to
access one of these vaults is a
challenge in and of itself that can take
you across an entire world once inside
you'll need to rely on skills from every
element of Andromeda gameplay including
exploration environmental navigation
puzzle solving and combat to get them
back online and then make it out alive
and resolving the mystery of these
vaults may just hold the key to survival
in Andromeda this is unbelievable at its
heart Mass Effect Andromeda is a game of
discovery and exploration the choices
you make in the places you go that you
blaze your own unique trail to enter
Amida whether you're exploring the
depths of a crash starship or delving
into the core of an active volcano the
more you engage with the world around
you and the characters in it the more
that world will surprise you with what's
waiting just around the corner it's
really gonna be something isn't it
you